-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden met yesterday
with Mexican President
Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
where he was surprised to learn
that that's all one guy.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Aw, man!
I thought I was meeting
with four soccer players.
[ Laughter ]
The White House
announced yesterday
that President Biden's attorneys
recently discovered
classified documents
while packing up
the Washington office he used
after serving as vice president,
in case you're wondering
why Tucker Carlson
did his show tonight
in full Joker makeup.
[ Laughter ]
The House yesterday approved
a set of rules
that will weaken
Speaker Kevin McCarthy's powers.
Really? How could they possibly
make him any weaker?
[ Laughter ]
They're already treating him
like a substitute teacher
on the last day of school.
[ Laughter ]
Are they going to make him
wear the "Kick me" sign
on the front?
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
yesterday
led a bipartisan group
of lawmakers
on a visit
to the Southern border
because, if there's one thing
Kyrsten Sinema loves,
it's when a sentence starts
with her name.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Republican Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeted a video of herself
walking in slow motion
through the halls of Congress
to the 1999 Dr. Dre song
"Still D.R.E."
Good God, madam,
have you no diggity?
[ Laughter and applause ]
She had to take it down.
True story.
Dre made her take it down.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Cease and desist.
She made a mistake.
She made a mistake they teach
you first day in law school.
She Forgot About Dre.
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans
are reportedly planning
to launch a panel this week
to investigate
White House communications
with big-tech companies.
Okay, well, we've seen
the latest tech
and it's definitely Republican.
[ Laughter ]
Disgraced cryptocurrency
executive Sam Bankman-Fried
has hired a pair
of defense attorneys
to join his legal team,
who previously worked
on cases involving
drug lord El Chapo
and convicted sex trafficker
Ghislaine Maxwell.
I guess he's hoping
third time's a charm?
[ Laughter ]
"Good news --
we got the Maxwell guy
and the Chapo guy."
New York's MTA yesterday
reopened 18 bathrooms
and 9 subway stations,
and then just this morning,
they very quickly closed
18 bathrooms
and 9 subway stations.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How?
It was only like 12 hours!
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in Arkansas
was arrested this week
after he allegedly used a hammer
to smash a hole
in the center of a church altar
and steal 1,500-year-old relics.
Not only has bail been posted,
but the movie has been optioned.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!